you're in absolute huge Blockbuster  gonna be probably one of the biggest  movies ever but also one of the biggest  movies this year you know as a kid you  always think oh man like that's cool  that's so cool you know this movie is  based on an African superhero yeah I  feel like I'm assuming yeah I'm about a  fight so why not first scene that I was  in I'm actually innocence my talking  scene I'm talking and I'm in front of  Angela Bassett you know just everyone  all the big actors in that room and I'd  have to explain to her what just  happened and and I remember I'm like it  was incredible just seeing them put it  all together the director Ryan he's the  coolest nicest he makes sure everybody's  good on set I'm nervous that you would  mess up your lines were you nervous to  like one line  one line I was scared I was going for  something live and I'm just showing all  of everyone going I'm just like  that is a pause Whose Line is it yeah  [Laughter]